[Musique]
je pense que c'est une bonne chose pour
les femmes et les jeunes filles qui sont
toutes seules sur la plage et qui ont
envie de passer un moment détente et de
ne pas se faire importuner
voilà la plage on se sent plus en
sécurité on a moins cela boule au ventre
ou alors on peut on se dit on y va plus
en détente et pas on se dit pas on va se
faire forcément se faire aborder et ça
va forcément nous embêter on va sûrement
repartir plus de la plage quoi
[Musique]
par exemple je prends un exemple je suis
harcelé au témoin donc tout simplement
moi en tant que médiateur je vais
recevoir automatiquement une
notification sur mon téléphone donc
grâce à la localisation ou la personne
elle est je vais lui envoyer je m'en
occupe tout simplement la victime à son
tour elle va recevoir une notification
pour lui dire pour la rassurer pour lui
dire qu'on arrive dans même pas les une
minute qui arrive
[Musique]
ce sont des personnes qui ont été
d'abord recrutés par la ville donc ça a
pris un temps et qui après sont passés
entre les mains de la société Orane pour
la formation à l'application SFR place
et ensuite sont allés faire de la
formation sensibilisation avec les
associations féministes c'est à dire on
n'est pas dans un gadget on est vraiment
dans la lutte contre le sexisme et les
agressions sexuelles
[Musique]